claude gensous madras d'abord parce que
c'est jocelyne ce qui est aussi parce
qu'il est l'auteur d'un livre que publie
aux éditions michel lafon
kinski j'ai besoin d'amour mais moi
honnêtement je ne sais pas si j'adorais
ce colosse kinski parce que vous avez
une horreur mélange absolu on le lit
dans votre livre des gens qui vous parle
des gens qui vous interviews et surtout
en plus il est un mec non au ses
dépenses et la fille est mignonne mais
comme sa maman suit
tout nom n'a pas tellement à l écran sur
liste femmes mais quand on a la balle
hachey tout ça vous connaissez bien bien
sûr mais
mais ça dépend plus à ça parce que du
thème en mars d'interviews qui sont
toujours en général être gratuit alors
j'ai demandé vraiment toujours à des
demandes les gens de demander à l'action
est ce que c'est une fille c'est une
fille savannah est ce que les jolies
autrement il dit toujours une jolie et
alors
je fais là rendez vous toujours là où je
pouvais échappe et eva joly alors c'est
arrivé comme ça vous voulez vous les
jolies pour les pc
non mais oh le joli parce que c'est plus
sympathique qui est de parler avec une
personne
qui est jolie qui est belle c'est à dire
pas seulement 7 trucks paris ciel des
comme les nez la bouche mais
une personne peut être très très belle
par son esprit et pour cent alors
voulez-vous les très belles oui vous
voulez vous les femmes et vous dites
j'entraîne tout ce que je peux attraper
comme un faux nez je bosse je bosse je
baise les vendeuses les serveuses est
bonne les femmes mariées les mères de
famille les [ __ ] d'haïti du
mozambique de la jamaïque des françaises
et wyse américaine me samba sy a tout
d'abord agrafes oui mais là elles sont
pas toutes belles quand même celle que
l'injure inez et non sur le lit par
terre aux toilettes sur le bidet par
derrière un genou sur levante debout
penché prémat vous avez lu livre non oui
alors vous n'avez pas à lire au pas
compris une note france qui se dit
qu'ils étaient très important vers la
fin de livre j'ai dit la plus grande
découverte qui j'ai fait dans ma vie et
en regardant le femme c'est tout les
femmes sont belles
d'ici jeudi tous les fronts belle alors
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça nul les la
discrimination ou je sais pas quoi là
qui vous essayé d'aider mais faire c'est
ridicule
gg c'est mon opinion je n'écris rien
dans le livre qui est pas vrai alors là
m'a rien à discuter sur les choses que
je l'écris vous énerve
un peu du but un peu parce que c'est pas
un bon début de parler avec moi j'ai
fait ça ailleurs des faits ça partout et
depuis toujours aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus conséquente que jamais parce que je
crois pas avant cette émission cela en
notre mission en natif dans des
magazines les journaux c'est pas pour
nous c'est pas nous ont masturbe laddh
c'est pour le public il faut avoir le
respect pour républicain adolescence il
faut donner beaucoup plus grand crédit
au public qui on donne au moins le même
qui en donne à soi même parce que parce
qu'il est gros mais oui je crois pas à
les gérer a acheté le livre n'était pas
la livre c'est pas une discussion à vous
avez là vous avez écrit là est la
sélection c'est des questions sont pas
idiots j'ai tiré sur son idiot je ne
réponds pas et
s'est amusé et là c'est pas le
partenaire pour mais amusé à cette
manière là bon alors dites moi
non écoutez vous devez bien avant
continue c'est pas la peine de continuer
de suivre cette manière parce que
j'ai pas le partenaire possède bon alors
le public vous n'en parlez jamais dans
votre livre
bien sûr elle est où les choses qui
devaient tous les autres que j'ai fait
dans ma vie les 269 voix j'ai fait va
pour moi même bah c'est inclus on parle
pas d'eux ici dans un pays je vous dis
j'aime beaucoup de pays et j'aime les
gens en parlent trop on part
gratuitement trop c'est connu d'ailleurs
sepalumic elissa ok alors on veut
toujours sur les trappes auchan non mais
ne pas faire de drame mais qu'est ce qui
veut dire parle pas assez jeune
accusations quoi pourquoi non mais tu
parlais dans mon livre de latif wpt
public pour savoir pourquoi non mais
vous me dites c'est à dire pour le
public gbe maintenant sa démission c'est
pas pour vous c'est pas pour moi non
c'est pour les gens qui vous espérez il
regarde il regarde si le prochain poids
et non mais oui mais des gens des gens
qui me regardent et joey mais je parle
est heureux laissez moi parler parce que
moi je suis là pour parler sinon mes
emmerdes
alors vous êtes lacs siphons masturber
vous même
bonsoir
[Musique]